l'assaut du capitole a été la
culmination d'une tentative de coup
d'état c'est la conclusion principale de
la commission d' enquête du congrès sur
la tacc du 6 janvier 2021 qui a commencé
à dévoiler ce soir la responsabilité
exacte de donald trump dans cette
insurrection est selon eux il serait
carrément au centre de la conspiration
qui visait à le maintenir au pouvoir un
an et demi après cette journée qui a
marqué l'histoire mille témoins et 140
mille documents plus tard c'est donc le
début des audiences publiques à heure de
grande écoute une véritable tempête
médiatique à washington et à z dès
l'ouverture on a appris qu'une partie de
l'entourage immédiat de donald chante ne
croyez pas que l'élection avait été volé
exactement parce que le thème des
manifestations c'est stop de style
arrêter le vol que dans le tome était
normalement président qu'on lui avait
volé ses élections là et là on apprend
qu en fait même son ministre de la
justice il avait beau chercher toutes
sortes de façons de dire que c'était des
fraudes il disait il il a dit au comité
qu'il ne croyait pas que c'était des
frottis que cette machine à voter vous
savez dans notre shop avaient dit qu'ils
avaient utilisé des machines à voter
dominion qui trichaient sur le résultat
des élections
il a dit vous vouliez me le disait qu'en
fait non il n'arrivait pas à justifier
injustifiée cela est d'emblée les
chenilles qui est la représentante
républicaine qui fait partie du comité
affirmé que dans notre chambre a
convoqué la foule incité la foule à à
manifester comme ça et surtout à allumer
la mèche de cette attaque écoutons
d'abord williams à bord l'ancien
ministre de la justice suivi des 24
chambres la fille de john holmes qui a
cru william balle en disant qu'à ce
moment là elle s'est dit non ce n'est
pas une fraude on les écoute
[Musique]
parmi les premiers témoignages on a
aussi entendu une policière qui a été
gravement blessées lors de cet assaut la
du capitole oui céline c'est
probablement le témoignage le plus
poignant alors elles expliquent dès le
début quand elle a été face à face aux
manifestants ils l'ont traité de traître
à la nation quelle était la chienne de
nancy pelosi ensuite elle a tenté
d'arrêter les manifestants de les
empêcher d'entrer dans le capital là
elle a perdu conscience parce que l
essayer de les empêcher elle est tombée
elle a perdu conscience et elle elle
disait qu'en fait elle a été entraînée
pour arrêter des suspects elle a été
entraînée pour contrôler des
manifestations mais n'a jamais était
entraîné pour une zone de combat si vous
voulez donc elle a parlé d'un carnage
que c'était le cas aux dans le capital
que jamais elle n'aurait imaginé que se
seraient produits aux états unis elle a
également affirmé que c'était la petite
fille d'un marines que c'était au
contraire une grande patriote qu'elle
n'avait pas à leur prouver cela et elle
se retrouvait dans son propre pays qui
était carrément en guerre écoutant un
extrait de ce qu'elle a dit
donc ces lignes ces audiences vont
souvent se pour virer ce qu'on s'en vont
se poursuivre par don est ce qu'on
essaie de démontrer c'est vraiment le
lien entre dans notre chambre et cet
assaut du capitole on essaie de montrer
qu'en fait ça a été organisée que tout
ceci c'était une stratégie elle une
stratégie derrière et ce qu'on a vu
aujourd'hui on a vu de nouveaux vidéos
qui ont été filmés par un documentariste
où on voit vraiment qu'il y avait
vraiment une préparation pour cet assaut
du capitole qu'on voulait renverser le
le vote le résultat électoral et
empêcher la certification des votes donc
ça va se poursuivre au courant de la
semaine prochaine là on verra si ça va
convaincre les américains merci hazeb
sens prêt